so today I want to come back to this guy
number two okay
lots out of this one lots of different
conclusions I want us to think about a
couple of examples we'll start with an
easy one okay division yeah how about ^
10 / ^ 7 okay same base division have a
look at the way the law works what
should I write on the right-hand side
let's go start with the - I heard -
right then what what will be in the
power it'll be three women it'll be ten
minus seven
in fact I might even write that ten
minus seven and that's where the three
controls which should be eight I guess
okay so that's fine that's a pretty so I
should put that three little close oh
that's a pretty plain example okay so
that was on example one look at another
example
I want to take this number three into
account as well what if one of these
indices here one of the powers with zero
for instance what's the first one with
zero times y and let's divide by or
something like how about that now going
through exactly the same thing that I
did here write division same base what
should I write on the right-hand side
hmm
now before I get to it five I'm gonna go
I'm gonna do this line right when I'm
dividing numbers with the same base I
subtract the indices and of course 0-5
like you've been telling me is negative
five okay but what does that mean this
is we haven't really encountered
negative indices before what the heading
is by the way so we want to work out
well what does it mean when you have a
negative index right and we're gonna do
it in a very similar way to how we treat
this remember how we thought about what
would happen if you had a zero index
what we're gonna do exactly the same
thing we
negative one okay have a look at this
left hand side again right from left
hand side shoot entire zero that's the
more number three isn't it
number three so what is to the power
zero it's just one exactly right one
okay now division I know we can rank
that divided time but I'm gonna write as
a fraction here like sir
right now I'm dividing by 2 to the power
of five right like so okay now have a
look at that line we've just written
look at this you've got this five here
and you've got the five a period n right
what's the difference between the two
sides on this side you've got the
negative index right what does it mean
hmm how would you what would you write
to explain what's going on um a negative
index there are cards in there out there
there's a high right I mean is 1/2 times
1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2
a negative index means and this would be
my summary sentence that you can put
Monique here means the base that - right
it moves to the denominator you see that
it becomes a fraction right
okay there's a is a funky rhyming way to
remember this which maybe you will find
really cheesy but hopefully it will help
which is that when you change the sign
of the index when you change the sign
you cross the line goes underneath onto
the bottom of the fraction okay so
that's how you can remember okay when I
see ^ negative something it's actually a
fraction right so just like over here
you see how all of these are not
examples then the laws right for any
number one of these mean we're gonna do
number seven now okay and it's come from
number two number three together how
would I write it you can write it like
this if I had a negative index like that
a negative power well I've changed the
sign so across the line
okay does that make sense that okay so
easy example okay
how about let's do three to the power of
negative two if I asked us to evaluate
that and find out what sequence you what
should I write well the sign their
native right so that means I'm gonna
write a fraction what's on the
denominator it'll be three squared okay
do you see that yeah see how it's
similar to this just the numbers are
slightly different so that's one over
nine yeah that's right that's right
exactly right
I suppose if I had another number like
say I can't let's do another example
let's go to two cubed times 3 5 this
time okay this one's a positive power so
it stays at the top right but this is a
negative power so it's gonna go down the
bottom like that you see what that means
so when you see these negative indices
what you really should be thinking about
is fractions okay that's what you get
out of them any questions on that does
that make sense yeah do you mean between
this and this between these two examples
um we just I got asked the question he's
always one in the answers well it's one
because this is really one times the
power of minus 2 if that was if that was
a negative as well yeah so that means
that would go into the denominator 2
okay
come in come in you said I'll turn the
handle it's
yeah davon I do a little bit right maybe
if it turns up aren't you know what's
your name
back here actually I'll see if I get my
free sorry no we up to you change this
to a negative so that means that means
it goes on the denominator as well like
that okay all the negative indices they
get on to the diode because you changed
the side across the line okay